it feels like is a little bit bubbly but
great companies are coming out of this
some of them are the ones you've
invested in slack intercom that's what
I'm saying I think we are we are very
fortunate to be in a bunch of companies
that are going to be iconic legacy
businesses what I'm saying is the next
you know 250 million dollar check I want
to write I'm more likely to just buy a
company outright or give that 250
million dollars to a company that isn't
looking to raise it but rather is like a
you know their last post was that 20
million and say hey listen what you're
doing is really kick ass it's probably
gonna take 25 years
here's 250 million based on these
milestones check in with me when you
need the extra money it's quite honestly
like I think that's a healthier way I
think you'll be more impactful and I
think again for me I will not be a part
of this charade anymore hmm I don't know
John I think the charade is dangerous
and it's particularly dangerous to these
companies it's very very dangerous to
you as founders because again at some
point the whole grow grow grow at all
costs runs out of juice you can no
longer acquire at a certain point
profitably in Google Facebook and Amazon
right your LTVs will get out of whack
right your gross margin positivity all
of a sudden - gross margin negativity I
mean forget about net profitability
these are fundamentally broken business
concepts they don't work they only work
if the money never stops but the money
never stops until as much time as people
can raise new funds and that's
predicated on people marking up old
deals you see how this whole thing like
at no point is there anything that comes
back to you the entrepreneur that says
what's your true poor product market fit
and is it working it's not part of the
conversation that is extremely dangerous
so it's I can't prognosticate and pick a
time that's not the point
but I think the point is that there has
to be much more sobriety in terms of how
companies grow and you know like I've
now thought to myself my gosh I would
love to grow and find a business that
can be they're growing 20 to 25% a year
for the next 15 years that violates all
the mechanics and all the gymnastics
with an adventure fund it's like grow at
400 because we know 400 eventually
decays to 12% a year but they don't care
by the time they're growing at 12% a
year because by the time foreigner
became 200 became 100 became 50 they've
raised two more funds they've marked up
the rest of their deals they've made
their fees ciao
so how does a founder protect against
and grow slow okay grow real grows long
Jeff Bezos grew Amazon and I mean this
what's so bananas like none of us go
back and look at the people we really
want to be like I'd like to be like that
guy he's in his 50s he's ripped
he's rich as [ __ ] and he's a genius yeah
okay that guy basically grew at 25
percent a year for [ __ ] 25 years I'm
sorry but that's drop the mic level
stuff there that's not yeah 408 percent
I don't know what's going on you know
you can't come out of the gate too fast
and I've learned that the hard way so
that's one really important thing I have
a very simple thing I draw on the box
now to my team I'm like here's a 2 by 2
matrix draw it out if you want ok this
x-axis is capital light capital heavy
x-axis the y-axis is obvious non obvious
wherever you are you want to be whether
you're obvious or non obvious you want
to be in that capital like column think
of where venture excels venture excels
and obvious meets capital heavy look at
scooters it's not them it's not to make
fun scooters is an exceptionally obvious
business model right well you'd say well
we had planes on charter 25 years ago
through NetJets we eventually had
smaller planes on charter then we had
buses on charter then we had limousines
on charter then we had cars on charter
then we had
cheaper cars on charter than we were
pooling cars then we had bicycles I mean
he literally did not have to be as smart
as you to take that trail of breadcrumbs
and say well what's the quantum of
transport that's smaller than a bicycle
but greater than your feet rollers
rollerblades rollerblades just littered
all over la San Francisco just
rollerblades ever put your feet in see
what happens yeah it could be anything
in there be anything in there needles or
big needles rat sees human dog yeah you
know by the way when you become mayor
and fix this town I'm gonna move back
here that's my commitment to you how I
get Mayor Jason calm approves so so
basically like but think about that
right but now think about how much money
has gone into that category billions and
in hundreds of them and have the Delta
of time that those companies have
existed 18 months 24 months but again
obvious capital heavy why because it
pays off the charade
get it in there fire it in buy some ads
blah Allah grow so fast get somebody
else put some more money and fire some
ads buy some growth blah blah blah Jesus
Christ I mean like is that is that how
great businesses get built in my opinion
probably not then you have people like
Elon and ease like well I'm gonna do the
other thing which is like Capital heavy
non-obvious
and basically unless you're as smart as
he is it's the dumbest thing to do
rocket ships rocket ship cars electric
cars
power walls then I would say there's the
rest of us and I would say non-obvious
are obvious you're not going to know a
priority but capital heavy capital light
you can control and I love this idea of
things like for example we're incubating
a company right now which I just
absolutely fundamentally love it is in a
non-obvious space that it's extremely
capital heavy and our approach is
basically unbelievably obvious to us
because we come from the internet and
it's exceptionally capital I think about
it as you know it takes 2 billion
dollars to launch a product
and you know that two billion dollars
because of how much it costs you need
like twenty thousand customers and we go
off and we find those twenty thousand
customers for two thousand dollars and
we're like two billion dollars is spent
to acquire these because what's going
what and so but instead what we said was
let's just seed it with 50k it's kind of
working let's put in another 200k that's
kind of work my point is there's a level
of disciplined I've arrived at now in
terms of the things that I think should
be how they how I like companies to be
built because otherwise you're always
going to be getting whipsawed by the fun
dynamics by what lp's are demanding of
the GPS by what GPS have issues with
with respect to compensation and so
there's a whole bunch of vagaries that
have nothing to do with you well you
know I'm building a house in Atherton at
least a fancy car yeah I'll do your deal
because I think it's growing fast enough
for somebody else will mark up my deal
that'll allow me to raise a new fund
which will allow me to get the 2% which
will allow me to increase my
compensation which will pay for my car
I'm sorry guys but like if you think
that that's not what's happening you're
lying to yourself
you are lying to yourself why are the
LPS going along with us I'm curious well
some LPS are actually unbelievably
superb you know I'll publish this in my
letter but like we looked at a
composition of our LPS and we're gonna
kind of expose this so people see but
80% of them are family offices and
they're exceptional because they are
like folks like us they're kind of like
grinders some of us got lucky some
didn't then some got really lucky and
they're all pretty like low-key and
you're like they want they want to be
around people like us and it's wonderful
they're builders roll up your sleeves
they're builders and then they value
building and they don't value all the
high-gloss veneer of service providers
you know service providers are very
intoxicating because they put up high
gloss veneer basically being a parasitic
blood sucking piece of [ __ ] on Honda
builder that's what I was gonna say
but uh anyway service providers aside
what the [ __ ] are we talking
oh yeah the LP is the good one now mints
kick-ass foundations kick-ass just
because like like you know we have a
couple of foundations who do a ton of
stuff in medical research and it's
inspiring we ultimately also you know
work with a couple of organizations that
allow the pensioners because we were
like we knew we were gonna make money
I've always known and I'm like I don't
want to make money for other rich people
now and I don't want to make money for
like Harvard like I want to make money
for like pensioners who work in a
non-profit because like they're like
yeah I'm gonna work at this hospital
because I want to help people and it's
so anyway so we have that and then the
the thing that I made a mistake is you
know at one point in time I let my
partners choose a few of the lp's and
you know they had a very different set
of incentives and I did and we ended up
admitting a bunch of fund of funds and
some were okay but there were a few that
were just horrible horrible rotten
people these two people that have in the
press and nonnamous letters yeah I'm not
sure I don't know cuz he's wrong I ought
to be honest with you Jason if I had to
really internalize I think a bunch of my
former partners said that does well like
at the end of the day I was tricking
myself and them this was a benevolent
dictatorship that I tried to pretend was
a democracy and I should have just owned
that and it's not to say that it's right
or wrong but I had the right to start a
company the way I wanted run my way with
on my terms I have earned that right and
I should have just been more honest with
everybody now was i honest in the docs
that everybody signed yes was i honest
and when their lawyers who I paid for
reviewed the things that said he has
absolute control and could do whatever
he wants and everyone's was that honest
yes but at the end of the day I was
still like guys it's a community you
know it's work together it's nice I like
what you think yes but then when push
came to shove big decisions I was like
sorry we're doing this sorry we're not
doing it right
and that's not for everybody and it was
for me
um yeah so you know those guys really
chafed at that yeah but yeah the people
that were that are sniping I attended a
press is there to basically you said
this incredibly well you know it's about
criticism and criticism is two things
the positive way that I took criticism
is what did I do wrong and how do I make
myself better as a human being and the
takeaway from there is I made a lot of
people feel very unworthy and unseen
because of my style and I have to be
more coherent and honest with my style
and allow people to choose whether to be
around it or not right but the second
part which is less about me and more
about them is like nobody remembers a
critic and at the end of the day critics
are there to basically amplify other
people's frustration so you can take the
little bit of it that's positive but
otherwise you got a block it out I mean
you guys are trying to build things
that's so hard nobody believes it's so
dark you're all alone last thing you
want is someone telling you that you
can't do it like [ __ ] those people
especially if they're just doing it to
get pageviews it's like bottom feeders
they're like anonymous irrelevant losers
on the sidelines you're on the field
doing things be proud that's amazing
that's hard that's hard good for you
yeah yeah yeah this one critic in the
history of critics who ever mattered who
was Roger Ebert and the reason Roger
Ebert was loved was because he was a fan
of new directors new projects and he was
just this tremendous supporter of the
art of cinema and it was and yet the
thing that you said before which is
truths like criticism really matters
when you're exposing you know deep
structural faults in a system
investigative journalists etc that kind
of criticism is important but you know
when you're talking about soul typing
when you're talking about sniping from
the sidelines about how Company A is
screwed and Company B is screwed and oh
my god this person lost an executive in
that person and it's like you know
nothing about nothing about nothing
because you're sitting there in your
dark little room toiling away bitterly
trying to be one of us and you're not
that's what you're doing and those
people don't matter no some people will
make things that matter
well on that I'm gonna just deal with
the fallout of this conversation for a
little while wait what is the fallout of
this conversation this conversation is
real
well no it's pre it was very real I
think it is they forgot something no
it's great because up until this moment
people were more worried about Elon than
you and now people more worried about
you than Elon so that makes it mean I'm
joking you know it's so funny like he
and I will make it through all we are
the nuclear cockroaches he and I exactly
you know we will survive you will
survive absolutely I talk to him as well
he's like everything's great cars are
going up and to the right and people are
on social media saying how much they
love the car what else is there it's
crazy like the product is loved it's the
greatest car ever made and people can't
get enough of them no we're both like
literally like it's like why does
everybody think things are so in it's
like again people want to validate page
of you clickbait but it doesn't map to
like what's really happening no the
reality is for a different all right on
that note let's hear it for month good
love you good luck all you guys yeah
[Applause]
[Music]